I feel like I'm an official Kardashian
assistant right now just lugging salad
around hey guys I'm Sam this is for
mando and Alex in the back and we're in
Calabasas we're about to try the salads
that you see I'm keeping up with the
kardashians that all your favorite
Kardashian women enjoy like all the time
they're always eating out of these
plastic bowls of lettuce on the show and
we were like we got to give them a try
the place that they get their cells from
it's called health nut and it's in
Calabasas it's about a 45 half an hour
minute drive from LA I'm personally
excited because they are filthy rich now
you always have all these great things
so these salads have to be really good
here we go oh it smells like Mike the S
house I think I like the look that they
have it's very like family Thanksgiving
call me cam and komando Kardashian those
are new Kardashian names it's dropped
over $100 I'm sorry all right so we're
back in the office and we have a bunch
of salad lots of salad we're gonna go
around and ask people what they think of
the health-nut Kardashian salad what do
you guys feel about Jenner family deco
people we love them can you stand them
but you also can't not see you I mean
differently respectful of their careers
yeah I don't want to but I know that
they have a show do you recognize the
salad from anywhere I mean it looks like
a plate of green it does look familiar I
believe this is one of the salads that
they eat very regularly in Calabasas
this salad creates a Kardashian ass
right okay that's why I feel very nerdy
that I know this many of their episodes
you see them ordering the salad eating
it in Chris's house like if you ever do
a Calabasas tour this is the fame
production salad Ben what do you think
of the Chinese chicken salad it's fine
pretty basic could get this anywhere
it's really good salad and the dressing
is really light it's not very heavy can
you see why kardashian-jenner ladies
like are constantly ordering these mhm
it's got a lot of protein it's a salad
so it's healthy and the dressing is
really excessive
I think the bowl style aesthetically
pleasing and plastic
my theory is they've been going here for
years pre fame only part of that life
that they have left to hold on to
hmm.you Sata's see why they order it
because they're trying to keep their
physique up can't see why they would
order this taste wise feel like a
Kardashian with this salad so that was a
very full day of kardashian-jenner
salads do you feel like you have gotten
a glimpse into their lives the
vegetables honestly every time I eat a
salad now I'm gonna think about it and
think that if it's not the salad we had
today it's not gonna be the ultimate
Kardashian experience yeah I lived
vicariously through a salad the fact
that when you're watching them eat the
salad you know what they are tasting how
many people can say they experienced
that not many and I'll say this I'm not
a big fan of the Kardashians like I
don't dislike them but I don't love them
but after having their salads and
realizing that it's not like a crazy-ass
salad I think they're more relatable and
it makes me look at them as real people
and unobtainable objects that people
think they are
[Music]